للمزيد ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من واشنطن
مراسلنا علي برد اهلا بك علي علي نقف معك
مع اهم ردود الفعل الامريكيه من هذه
المقابله الطويله العريضه والذي بدا فيها
بوتين وكانه يقدم درسا في التاريخ حول
تاريخ روسيا
للامريكيين بطبيعه الحال دارس في التاريخ
لن يعجب امريكيون ب يعني المطالعه
التاريخيه التي قدمها بوتين وهي ليست
جديده هم معتادون على مثل هذه المطالعات
التاريخيه في شان عظمه روسيا وحدود روسيا
وان اجزاء من اوكرانيا كانت عبر التاريخ
جزء من روسيا لم يحصل بعد رد فعل رئيسي من
الولايات
المتحده على
هذه عفوا على هذه المقابله التي على رغم
انها يعني كانت ممله في جوانب منها
ويحاول الوصول الى الراي العام الامريكي
الراي العام الامريكي مشغول الان بقضايا
مختلفه بعمر الرئيس جو بايدن وترشحه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه وزلات لسانه وبا
احتمال
عوده الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب الى
البيت الابيض هذا الراي العام الامريكي
ربما لا تصل اليه الرسائل المهمه التي
ارسلها بوتين في هذا اللقاء وهو اولا ان
روسيا تفكر في الحوار مع الولايات المتحده
وال المناقشات حول القضايا المختلفه في
خلافات روسيا مع الغرب عموما والولايات
المتحده هي المحاور الرئيسي الذي يتطلع
اليه الرئيس بوتين ولكن لكن ايضا هناك
قضايا مهمه
للغايه اولا هو قال من الصعب هزيمه روسيا
ولم يتحدث عن انتصار روسيا يتطلع الى
الحوار اكثر من مما يتطلع
الى الانتصار العسكري على الارض في
اوكرانيا
والحوار وكان واضحا في هذه الرسائل وقال
ان الولايات
المتحده مشغوله بقضاياها الانتخابيه
بقضايا الحدود والتضخم والديون وكل ما الى
ذلك
وهذه ابقى معنا وانت قلتها وانت قلتها ان
الراي العام الامريكي مهتم بزلات اللسان
فقط لمشاهدينا كي نذكر الى الى ماذا كان
يشير مراسلنا من واشنطن ان الرئيس
الامريكي مشاهدينا واليوم كان قد حاول ان
يبرر ذلته ذله لسانه الجديده وقال ان صحته
العقليه وذاكرته بحاله جيده معتبرا ان
المدعي الخاص روبرت هور وجه اتهامات باطله
بشان ذاكرته
وكبر سنه بهذا الشان علي برد اعود بك لان
هذه القضيه على ما يبدو اليوم التي تشغل
بال الامريكيين والتي يستغلها خصومه على
راسهم دونالد
ترامب ت تماما تماما هذا ما ارد ان اقوله
ان ما ما قاله بوتين يتجاوب او يتردد
دائما في الا في اوساط المحافظين ولا سما
الرئيس دونالد ترامب الذي يشهد يوما
استثنائيا اولا هو نجح في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه في نيفادا بفارق كبير على غرار
الولايات
السابقه
ثانيا المحكمه العليا تتجه الى قول ان انه
لا يمكن ازاله اسم الرئيس السابق من
اللوائح الانتخابيه كما تريد ولايه مثل
كولورادو وولايه اخرى مثل مين اما الرئيس
جو بايدن فكان يومه سيء اذا جاز التعبير
الساعات الماضيه اولا بعد هذا التقرير
الذي اصدره المستشار الخاص
لوزاره العدل في شان قضيه وصول الوثائق
السريه
الى جراج في منزل
بايدن
براه المستشار الخاص ولكن المستشار الخاص
تحدث عن امور مهمه للغايه بالنسبه
للامريكيين تحدث عن الصحه العقليه للرئيس
جو بايدن وعن زلاته
وعن مواضيع مختلفه مثيره ل الجدل ويتحدث
فيها الراي العام الامريكي وفوق ذلك
ما زاد طين بلا ان الرئيس بايدن دعا الى
مؤتمر صحافي على عجل في محاوله للرد على
هذا التقرير وعلى ما ورد فيه في شان صحته
العقليه وفي شان ذاكرته
فحصلت خلال هذا اللقاء الصحافي السريع
زلات اضافيه منها مثلا قوله
ان يحاول معال جت الامر على الحدود
الجنوبيه مع الرئيس السيسي بدلا من ان
يقول مع الرئيس المصري بدلا من ان يقول مع
الرئيس المكسيكي وهذه زادت ايضا علامات
الاستفهام الموجوده
اصيلي ونانسي
بيلوسي ذاك كان الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب الذي خلط في هذه المساله ولكن هناك
اكثر من ذله لسان حصلت خصوصا مع الرئيس جو
بايدن فنحن في الولايات المتحده نواجه
الان هذه
ال المشكله الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
عمره
77 عاما وهو كبير السن والرئيس الحالي جو
بايدن عمره 21 عاما وهذه مشكله ايضا هناك
الراي العام الامريكي يتساءل الا يوجد
مرشح جدي لدى كل من الحزب الجمهوري والحزب
الديمقراطي يعني ان يكون
عمره لم يدخل بعد في سن الرشد على غرار ما
كان يحصل في الاتحاد السوفيتي عندما يصل
الزعيم بعد ما يكون على في نهايات
السبعينات من العمر وهذا ما نشهده الان في
الولايات المتحده ليس كما يحصل عندكم في
فرنسا الرئيس ماكرون لا يزال شابا
وا رئيس الوزراء
ايضا شاب ووزير الخارجيه ايضا من الشباب
الوضع مختلف هنا في الولايات المتحده
وهناك نوع من من الغيره والحسد بين
الولايات المتحده وفرنسا في هذا الامر
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك علي برده مراسلنا من
واشنطن